people are seeing this first-person
stuff all the time but it's always this
technique of using a Steadicam and green
screening arms in front of a camera
because there's no simple good solution
to actually shooting it practically
finally it's like there is a device that
literally just was made and and it's
stabilizes at all and it's a gimbal just
like everything else except now you can
wear Preston's like that's all right
there cool we're using these cool little
video tech gimble's and GoPros to
capture stuff from a really buttery
smooth perspective butter smooth give
our toe step everyone in the studio has
their own visual effects specialty it's
like Captain Planet and the Planeteers
basically rents handling the Mega Man
effects which are incredible looking the
Harry Potter effects and a few other
various ones so what's cool about the
Mega Man Dan wand effects is that
they're all done inside of After Effects
they're just simple particle simulations
using a plug-in called trapcode
particular the 3d camera tractor scene
you designate your ground plane and
maybe a few walls for the particles to
interact with and the mega main and
stupefy shots are essentially the same
effect with different particle
appearances even the avada kedavra is a
particle stream to finish it off you
just throw on a bunch of glow effects
and optic flares make it look nice
the fake Lancer has a chainsaw that
doesn't actually work thankfully so to
pull that effect off you just isolate
the teeth from a still frame and then D
warp it to straighten it out from there
you can infinitely animate it to get
that sawing motion then you can read a
store it it and retrack it back them to
the guns make it look like it was always
there just be sure to paint out the
original teeth or to look weird okay so
for the gruesome blood I needed an
actual fluid simulation program called
real flow with it you can simulate
different particles to behave like a
liquid and then mesh them into a 3d
object once meshed you can render out
different angles of the same simulation
to composite back onto your footage
since here's a war as a game is very
over-the-top we decided to make the
blood effects equally over the top and
just insane it's all just ridiculous
Nikko is widely known as the fume
effects master around the place so he is
actually handling stuff like the Mario
buyer hands all right so for the
fireballs I had to use a plug-in called
fume effects which simulates gaseous
fluids and how they move in the air
I had to test different settings get
just the right amount of flame lengths
smoke amount and fire turbulence once
that was dialed in I had to build up the
scene with some particle emitters
spitting out bouncing balls that would
eventually be lit on fire using fumefx a
good simulation comes from recreating
the random dynamic nature of real-life
air and fire I built of elements of the
scene that could interact with the fire
making it feel real and connected to the
environment particularly Robbie here
flailing his arms finally I had to add
some shadows to make the smoke feel like
it was actually in the space and some
artificial lighting to make the fire
feel real as well for me I suck at
everything so basically I'm rotoscoping
the whole video okay since this video
has so many CG effects I think really
worth the time to make sure we did do
some practical stuff in here once again
we're working with the cool guys from
EMC stunts yeah basically they were
taking all the hits and doing all the
jumps and flips and yeah it kind of
helps balance out the video and make the
effects seem a lot cooler yeah we only
have three actual stuntmen on set Tony
and Malloy and Robbie basically we just
brought extra cops villains three and a
half blue-eyed black folks green vest it
works you're also thinking about where
the camera is yeah did I get the big
shotgun right oh yeah everything is
perfect in that shot and what what does
it affect we're just like spraying in
every single shot we're flipping through
stuff each effect is different so the
moment you build out an effect it's like
well that's all you're gonna use of it
because the gun switches the weapon
switches and you need a new effect
already you're rebuilding slipping so
yeah there's nothing reusable that's the
funniest part about this whole thing
let's talk about that big shot just
really briefly it is the shot that has
one of the largest amount of changes and
I guess environment pack 11 and
practical stuff yeah let's see if we are
starting with a mini gun on top of a
generator that we have to jump down from
and then we actually cut into a new take
there because jumping with the mini gun
it's not really feasible and then the
rest of the sequence there plays out as
a single tape blending two tapes
together with that jump we are then
doing a portal fight which requires very
specific geometry of the scene and then
on top of that you move into a practical
stunts it was definitely the biggest
shot it took the longest to set up and
the first time we went through it we
rehearse it about five times everything
was working great and then we did the
shot everything worked out perfectly and
at the end
Tony fell off of the roof then onto the
boxes and he fell in such a way that he
landed on his feet a lot of lot of
weapons hallo it's alright fall
pulse rifle from halflife de master
sword we have the Minecraft sword we
have the minecraft bow portal gun we
have a mini gun we have the normal guns
you have the Megaman blaster the Harry
Potter wand the Lancer the chainsaw on
it
one thing that's super awkward though is
fighting with a wearable gimbal rig on
your chest with a frame that's only
about as wide as your chest and you have
to keep your hands in the middle of it
yeah try sword fighting while looking
down fast and having people swing boys
at your face it's really really nervous
huh yeah don't hurt yourself
yeah don't do it don't don't make this
video basically each time you get a kill
you get a new gun and in the video game
you literally just get a new gun
instantly how do you do that in real
life though Cameron and Sherwin were the
the gun monkeys yeah so basically we
just practice it out it's kind of like
just passing the baton and back and feel
also huge thanks to Hollywood Sports
Park for hooking us up with their sweet
locations again so I bet you guys have
also been wondering how come your behind
the scenes videos looks so good all the
time well actually it's because of a few
things
the first of which is Carmichael's great
and the other thing is the aperture deck
it's a really cool electronic canon lens
to Sony e-mount adapter it's been great
because previously from the first days
of us using the Sony fs100 we've been
using a bunch of other janky lenses
we've been using all these adapters that
don't allow us to get all the electronic
data from the lens into the camera
aperture deck does all that we've been
using all our Canon lenses that we use
on our read on this same camera as well
we just want to give the guys at
aperture big shout-out for helping us I
would love to ask you something will you
go out with me if you didn't learn
something that's our fault
let us know go back watch it again watch
it again you probably missed the thing
we're trying to teach you if you enjoyed
our gun game video as much as we liked
making it please check out our patreon
page we have everything from high
quality downloads of these videos which
are really fun to watch on your
big-screen TV we have live stream
tutorials and Q&A sessions we have
project files so you can actually get
our project files and our customized
stock elements if you guys decide to
check it out we would really appreciate
it and would really like your support
with that being said I hope you guys
consider subscribing as well and
every day he's up in the next video
laughs and reveals his darkest filming
secrets
damn it Sam got Jeremy damn it all right
look sorry one more thing this is gonna
be perfect
right